[Music]
[Applause]
a Conan O'Brien here this is my blog I'm
in my bedroom right now so you can see
it's pretty pretty sweet
those are my posters back there and
anyway here's what's going on in my
world
mom-mom turn your back you okay I'd like
to start with a segment from my blog
called black people photobombing Donald
sterling glad people photobombing Donald
sterling
these are photos of black people
photobombing Clippers owner Donald
sterling there's a little Wayne right
there we got Oprah Winfrey right here I
like this one samuel l.jackson he's just
not having it and of course there's
Madea black people
what a bombing Donald sterling black
people photobombing Donald sterling this
next piece I came up with is a new
segment called supreme smurf justices
supreme smurf justices i didn't push the
button this is where I take pictures of
Supreme Court justices and then Smurf em
up in Photoshop it takes a long time
check it out here's justice Smurf Scalia
there's Justice Ruth Bader Smurf burg
and justice Clarence Papa Smurf Tommy
[Music]
supreme smurf justices
[Laughter]
[Applause]
now it's time for one called bridges
that lead to giant snacks bridges that
lead to giant snacks this is bad here
here's the Brooklyn Bridge leading to a
giant chocolate chip cookie right there
here's the Golden Gate Bridge leading to
a giant bag of trail mix here's a
Bridges of Madison County going through
a Pringle tunnel to get to a snake
[Music]
not in the script alright
this last bit last bits called messing
with Godzilla's roar messing with
Godzilla's roar
I took Godzilla's roar from the new
movie trailer and I mess with it check
this out there's another one
[Music]
[Applause]